وفي حديث خاص للجزيره قال رئيس جزر القمر
الرئيس الحالي للاتحاد الافريقي غزالي
عثمان ان الحرب في السودان خطيره لانها
ستؤثر على قاره افريقيا باكملها واشار
عثمان في حديثه الخاص للجزيره الا ان على
طرفي الصراع في السودان ان يعلم انه لا
منتصر في هذه الحرب وانها لابد ان تتوقف
جونغكوك
الازمه في السودان هي بالفعل مشكله خطيره
ليس فقط على السودان الذي يعتبر بلدا يقع
في قلب افريقيا وتحيط به سبع دول ما يعني
ان الازمه ليست محصوره على السودانيين بل
الافريقيا كلها هناك الكثير من الاجراءات
التي يتم تنفيذها من طرف الاتحاد الافريقي
وانا شخصيا على اتصال بالطرفين المتحاربين
لمحاوله اقناعهما للجلوس للتفاوض وانهاء
الحرب نحن ندرك ان هذه الحرب لا يمكن لاحد
ان ينتصر فيها وبالتالي يجب ان تتوقف لان
عواقبها ستكون وخيمه على السودان وعلى
افريقيا